I save tens of thousands maybe hundreds  of thousands of lives by her main  argument is that you bought yourself  some time you didn't do just to prepare  hospitals you didn't use it to ramp up  testing right so you so you so  disgraceful it's so just graceful the  way you said it  let me just listen I just went over it I  just nobody thought we should do it and  what I did it what you do what do you do  when you have no case in a whole United  States when you excuse me you reported  it zero cases zero deaths on January 17  Daniel I said in Jenny on January 30 and  in fact we'll give you a list what we  did in fact part of it was up there we  did a lot look you know you're a fake  you know that your whole network the way  you cover it is fake